you were nearly in this world weren't
you them awful Wow make me feel great
look at this poster John you almost hit
that choice Captain America but you were
in the costume and everything me got
pretty good yeah I got to the suit it
was a pretty big day for me
I was hurting out completely and I got a
say for a split second there was feeling
really good about myself comes up and
they give you the suit you get it I give
you the suit and I was actually putting
the suit on I was like oh my god this is
so amazing and through the hallway came
chris hemsworth dressed his Thor and
he's like all right Knight no no
[Laughter]
no yeah when you see Chris Hemsworth
with next to no clothes you don't want
all of a sudden be like I want to take
my clothes they like tool and I'm not
that tool
I'm never doing a scene on a planet and
there's all these like little dips and
rocks and stuff and I just said to
myself in rehearsal just find a rock
wait stop find a nice rock maybe find
first rehearsal I hopped up on the rock
and I'm working with Chris Pratt you
know Chris I was like chin height you
know I'm happy I'm happy here and then
they're setting up the lights and stuff
I'm hanging out and I end up in a hole
no and I said to myself just make sure
that you're not here when their action
stood in this little hole smaller than
all these people and I'm gonna be polite
I was waist height I spent three days
[Music]